they're exhausted after three months on
the front lines around bakmut this
Battalion is now rotated out but just
for a short while
these Ukrainian soldiers have been
chosen to join an animal therapy session
as they've been showing symptoms of
post-traumatic stress disorder anxiety
depression sleepless nights
you just feel calm around animals an
animal is gentle to you it calms you
Oleg has been in the Army since 2014.
war is not new to him we ask him what it
is like in Bahamut
um
he doesn't want to talk about it
the mental toll this war is taking on
countless soldiers is not something
widely talked about the scale is still
unknown programs like this are not that
common but it's a start
Imes
when they arrive here they are tents
maybe a little apprehensive because they
don't know what will happen but after a
few hours they forget everything they
manage to relax and get some new
positive emotions sometimes their eyes
light up like a child's some say their
sleep improved after this
this program ultimately connects them
with horses and it's called hippotherapy
it feels a world away from the front
line
all part of a therapeutic process which
ultimately has them mounting up these
soldiers have never ridden a horse
before and now this program runs twice a
week and it's never the same group that
passes through the aim is to offer some
kind of light relief even if just
temporary as they will be returning to
the front lines in just a few days there
is a scientific formula to this we're
told
when you're on a horse every muscle of
your body is working you have to find
your balance to not fall you have to
focus on your body that's what we're
aiming for with the horse because if a
person is under stress they don't feel
their body they're numb there are lots
of soldiers with signs of PTSD so we
work on that a childlike moment of
relief for men who carry the burden of
defending their country we ask if it has
helped
[Music]
I feel quite different it is
incomparable here we rest physically and
mentally yeah it is totally different
from there it's hard you don't think
you do your job that's it ukrainians too
are dying in large numbers the exact
figure is hard to verify Oleg tells us
they need more support around
I see that we are not so prepared we
need more Hardware we don't have as much
training as we should men are fighting
who have never served in the army
he says they are due to return to the
front line on Saturday
that is that he tells us
an affectionate Moment Like This
providing all too fleeting comfort
we filmed with these men a few days ago
they are now back on the front line
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera Kiev